What I want to do in this
video is give ourselves
a basic introduction to
the phenomenon of light.
And light is, at least
to me, mysterious.
Because on one level it
really defines our reality.
It's maybe the most defining
characteristic of our reality.
Everything we see, how
we perceive reality,
is based on light
bouncing off of objects
or bending around objects or
diffracting around objects,
and then being
sensed by our eyes,
and then sending signals
into our brain that
create models of the
world we see around us.
So it really is, almost,
the defining characteristic
of our reality.
But at the same time, when you
really go down to experiment
and observe with
light, it starts
to have a bunch of
mysterious properties.
And to a large degree it is
not fully understood yet.
And probably the most
amazing thing about light--
well, actually there's tons of
amazing things about light--
but one of the mysterious things
is when you really get down
to it-- and this is actually
not just true of light,
this is actually true
of almost anything
once you get onto a small enough
quantum mechanical level--
light behaves as both
a wave and a particle.
And this is probably not
that intuitive to you,
because it's not
that intuitive to me.
In my life, I'm used to certain
things behaving as waves,
like sound waves or
the waves of an ocean.
And I'm used to certain things
behaving like particles,
like basketballs or-- I
don't know-- my coffee cup.
I'm not used to things
behaving as both.
And it really depends on
what experiment you run
and how you observe the light.
So when you observe
it as a particle,
and this comes out
of Einstein's work
with the photoelectric effect--
and I won't go into the details
here, maybe in a
future video when
we start thinking about
quantum mechanics--
you can view light as a
train of particles moving
at the speed of light, which
I'll talk about in a second.
We call these particles photons.
If you view light in other
ways-- and you see it
even when you see light being
refracted by a prism here--
it looks like it is a wave.
And it has the
properties of a wave.
It has a frequency, and
it has a wavelength.
And like other waves,
the velocity of that wave
is the frequency
times its wavelength.
Now even if you ignore this
particle aspect of light,
if you just look at the
wave aspect of the light,
it's still fascinating.
Because most waves require
a medium to travel through.
So for example, if I think about
how sound travels through air--
so let me draw a bunch
of air particles.
I'll draw a sound wave traveling
through the air particles.
What happens in a sound wave
is you compress some of the air
particles and those compress
the ones next to them.
And so you have points in
the air that have higher,
I guess you could
say, higher pressure
and points that
have lower pressure,
and you could plot that.
So we have high
pressure over here.
High pressure, low pressure,
high pressure, low pressure.
And as these things
bump into each other,
and this wave essentially
travels to the right--
and if you were to plot
that you would see this wave
form traveling to the right.
But this is all
predicated, or this is all
based on, this energy
traveling through a medium.
And I'm used to visualizing
waves in that way.
But light needs no medium.
Light will actually travel
fastest through nothing,
through a vacuum.
And it will travel at an
unimaginably fast speed--
3 times 10 to the eighth
meters per second.
And just to give
you a sense of this,
this is 300 million
meters per second.
Or another way of
thinking about it is it
would take light less
than a seventh of a second
to travel around the earth.
Or it would travel around the
earth more than seven times
in one second.
So unimaginably fast.
And not only is this
just a super fast speed,
but once again it
tells us that light
is something fundamental
to our universe.
Because it's not just an
unimaginable fast speed.
It is the fastest speed not just
known to physics, but possible
in physics.
So once again something
very unintuitive to us
in our everyday realm.
We always imagine
that, OK, if something
is going at some speed, maybe if
there was an ant riding on top
of that something and it was
moving in the same direction,
it would be going even faster.
But nothing can go faster
than the speed of light.
It's absolutely impossible based
on our current understanding
of physics.
So it's not just
a fast speed, it
is the fastest speed possible.
And this right here
is an approximation.
It's actually 2.99
something something times 10
to the eighth meters per second.
But 3 times 10 to the
eighth meters per second
is a pretty good approximation.
Now within the visible
light spectrum-- and I'll
talk about what's beyond
the visible light spectrum
in a second-- you're probably
familiar with the colors.
Maybe you imagine them as
the colors of the rainbow.
And rainbows really
happen because the light
from the sun, the white
light, is being refracted
by these little water particles.
And you can see that
in a clearer way when
you see light being refracted
by a prism right over here.
And the different wavelengths
of light-- so white light
contains all of the
visible wavelengths--
but the different wavelengths
get refracted differently
by a prism.
So in this case the
higher-frequency wavelengths,
the violet and the blue,
get refracted more.
Its direction gets bent
more than the low-frequency
wavelengths, than the reds and
the oranges right over here.
And if you want to look at the
wavelength of visible light,
it's between 400 nanometers
and 700 nanometers.
And the higher the frequency,
the higher the energy of that
light.
And that actually
goes into when you
start talking about the
quantum mechanics of it--
that the higher frequency means
that each of these photons
have higher energy.
They have a better ability
to give kinetic energy
to knock off electrons or
whatever else they need to do.
So higher frequency--
let me write
that down-- higher frequency
means higher energy.
Now I keep referring to this
idea of the visible light.
And you might say, what
is beyond visible light?
And what you'll find
is that light is just
part of a much
broader phenomenon,
and it's just the part
that we happen to observe.
And if we want to broaden
the discussion a little bit,
visible light is
just really part
of the electromagnetic spectrum.
So light is really just
electromagnetic radiation.
And everything that I told
you about light just now--
it has a wave property and
it has particle properties--
this is not just specific
to visible light.
This is true of all of
electromagnetic radiation.
So at very low frequencies
or very long wavelengths--
we're talking about
things like radio waves,
the things that allow a
radio to reach your car;
the things that
allow your cellphone
to communicate with cell towers;
microwaves, the things that
start vibrating water
molecules in your food
so that they heat
up; infrared, which
is what our body
releases, and that's
why you can detect
people through walls
with infrared cameras; visible
light; ultraviolet light,
the UV light coming from the
sun that'll give you sunburn;
X-rays, the
radiation that allows
us to see through the soft
material and just visualize
the bones; gamma rays,
the super high energy
that comes from quasars
and other certain types of
physical phenomena-- these
are all examples of
the exact same thing.
We just happen to perceive
certain frequencies
of this as visible light.
And you might say, hey,
Sal, how come we only
perceive certain
frequencies of this?
How can we only see
these frequencies?
Literally we can see
those frequencies
with our unaided eye.
And the reason, or at
least my best guess
of the reason of that, is
that's the frequency where
the sun dumps out a lot of
electromagnetic radiation.
So it's inundating the Earth.
And if, as a species, you
wanted to observe things
based on reflected
electromagnetic energy,
it is most useful to be able to
perceive the things where there
is the most
electromagnetic radiation.
So it is possible that in other
realities or other planets
there are species
that perceive more
in the ultraviolet range
or the infrared range.
And even on Earth,
there are some
that perform better at
either end of the range.
But we see really well in
the part of the spectrum
where the sun just happens to
dump a lot of radiation on us.
Now I'll leave you there.
I think that's a pretty
good overview of light.
And if any of this
stuff seems kind
of unintuitive or
daunting, or really
on some level confusing--
this wave-particle duality,
this idea of a transfer of
energy through nothing--
and it seems
unintuitive, don't worry.
It seems unintuitive even
for the best of physicists.
So you're already at the leading
edge of physics thinking.